-Performing "America,"
please welcome Will Swenson
and the cast
of "A Beautiful Noise,"
the Neil Diamond musical.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
-It was more than 100 years ago
that a little girl made
the great voyage
-♪ Ooh ooh ooh ooh
ooh ooh ooh ♪
-to a place called America.
That little girl
was my grandmother.
She and her daughter Rose
inspired me
to achieve everything that I've
achieved in my life.
Her courage will never be
forgotten.
This one is for her.
-♪ Far ♪
♪ We've been traveling far ♪
♪ Without a home ♪
♪ But not without a star ♪
♪ Free ♪
♪ Only want to be free ♪
♪ We huddle close ♪
♪ And hang on to a dream ♪
-♪ On the boats
and on the planes ♪
♪ They're coming to America ♪
♪ Never looking back again ♪
♪ Home ♪
♪ Don't it seem so far away? ♪
♪ Oh, we're traveling
light today ♪
♪ In the eye of a storm ♪
-♪ Storm ♪
-♪ Home ♪
♪ To a new and a shiny place ♪
♪ Make our bed,
we'll say our grace ♪
♪ Freedom's light burning warm ♪
♪ Freedom's light
burning warm ♪
-♪ Warm ♪
-♪ On the boats
and on the planes ♪
♪ They're coming to America ♪
♪ Never looking back again ♪
♪ Everywhere around the world ♪
♪ They're coming to America ♪
♪ Every time
that flag's unfurled ♪
♪ They're coming to America ♪
♪ Today ♪
-♪ They're coming to America ♪
-♪ Today ♪
♪ Today ♪
-My county 'tis of thee.
-♪ Today ♪
-Sweet land of liberty.
-Of thee I sing.
-♪ Today ♪
-♪ They're coming to ♪
♪ America ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-The cast
of "A Beautiful Noise,"
the Neil Diamond musical.
Go see it on Broadway
at the Broadhurst Theatre.
For tickets, go to
abeautifulnoisethemusical.com.